blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try it for free
and get 25 off a subscription by going
to blinkist.com
pakman so yesterday i interviewed ben
dixon host of the benjamin dixon show
and we talked about what could joe biden
focus on
next early last week the rumor was the
report was
that tax reform would be next after
covet relief
now being done uh earlier this week we
heard
it's going to be a three trillion dollar
infrastructure
schools and families package which will
be next
but in the back of all of this is the
push to expand
voting rights and there's of i would
argue a very
strong case to be made that the
advantage of going next to voting rights
is twofold number one it's of paramount
importance to win
elections that as many people be able to
vote as possible
uh and that republicans not be allowed
to succeed with what they are doing
remember that republicans in the
aftermath of the 2020 election
launched proposed wrote are starting to
work on
more than 250 different voter
suppression bills across
more than 40 states so not only
is the issue of expanding voting rights
relevant for winning elections
it's of particularly timely importance
because republicans are trying to do the
exact opposite
in addition to this there's the context
of the filibuster now we'll get in a
moment to what is in the voting rights
bill that the house passed but if you
were thinking as democrats are
we may need to do something with the
filibuster to get things done in the
next two years
with democrats having the white house
house and senate
and it's the filibuster being there that
may prevent us from doing that
is there any better issue over which we
could
justify doing again it's a modification
of the filibuster elimination we don't
know
but what would be a better case to make
than this is about voting republicans
are blocking
voting rights we must do something with
the filibuster so that's the
if you want to make a case for why it
should indeed be
voting rights expansion that should be
focused on first
you could make the case that it's
because republicans
are actively doing the opposite so
democrats must push back against those
250 bills
because if you believe you'll need
filibuster changes to get other things
done
it's probably politically more viable
to justify changing the filibuster over
something as important as
like listen you know with guns i think
it would be justified in theory to
modify the filibuster to try to get
things done
but i think from a public relations
standpoint it would be more difficult
with something like we this is voting
rights
you arguably have the most justifiable
reason to do it
now would there be any republican
support for this voting rights bill in
the senate my
understanding is and again
this is a topic that often there's
disagreement about
i don't believe that there's a budget
reconciliation argument to be made for
voting rights because it's not
uh it's not a budget issue it's not a
spending issue although certainly some
of the initiatives
cost money maybe i'm wrong and you could
do voting rights via budget
reconciliation i've not read anything so
far that says you could
um and in the house the 800-page bill
passed
basically along party lines and it does
a ton of stuff not all of which
republicans want much of which some
republicans
want none of this bill would create
minimum standards for states in terms of
how they must run
elections federal standards that states
must abide by
it would basically destroy a lot of the
voter id
proposals and laws in a variety of
different states
it would restore voting rights to former
felons period not
states will vote um as as a
referendum no it just it restores voting
rights to former felons
it puts in place requirements like
automatic voter registration
no excuse mail-in balloting which means
you don't need
a qualifying reason to
explain why you want to vote by mail you
can just say
i want to vote by mail and that's it and
a lot of these provisions are the exact
opposite of what republicans
at the state level are doing now it's
important to remember many of the
republicans in the senate
who would be voting on this bill don't
necessarily have the same perspective or
opinion on these issues
as the state level republican
legislators that are working on
the ant on the voter suppression bills
but still i don't know that you get any
republican support for this the other
thing is on gerrymandering and
gerrymandering we've talked about
many times over the years this bill
that has passed the house and you know
we'll see what happens in the senate
would require states to use independent
commissions to draw congressional
districts
and right now this would significantly
hurt republicans
you could imagine a situation in the
future where
it's democrats who have gotten to draw
the majority of the districts
and such a provision could hurt
democrats but remember that even
who gets to draw the districts aside
because of the urban rural divide
um it favors republicans in in terms of
district drawing at a sort of core level
so that's a huge deal republicans know
that part of the reason they win some
districts
in purple states even in red states is
by drawing them in very particular ways
that we've exposed before
so this is a this is a major deal if it
could be done
and what needs to be balanced by joe
biden and by democrats here in terms of
determining whether this is the next
thing that they want to deal with
is number one the importance and the
urgency
given that there's an election now in
what two
five minus twenty 19 months we're 19
months from the midterms
and if republicans just do what they're
doing in all of these different states
it will hurt the left in 2022 there's no
doubt so there's that urgency
there's the justification for using
enfranchisement
as a valid reason
to do something with the filibuster
maybe do away with
maybe just reform it mandate a talking a
mandated talking filibuster
maybe make some other changes uh and
because
it could set up the possibility
of the infrastructure plan and of other
things
uh in the remainder of these first two
years of joe biden's term so that's the
gist of it i'm curious to hear from you
what do you want joe biden and democrats
focusing on next
should it be the tax reform plan which i
think politically is the most
um difficult at this point in time given
the circumstances with the pandemic and
economy which we'll talk about in a
moment
should it be the infrastructure spending
plan where there is
maybe some more republican support but
they will be opposed to much of it
or is it the voting rights expansion let
me know what you would like to see
joe biden and democrats tackle next we
have
good news this is good news from the
standpoint of being less
bad u.s weekly new jobless claims
are at their lowest level since the
start of the coronavirus pandemic
there was a bigger than expected drop in
new unemployment claims that we learned
about yesterday
we are at a pandemic era low the
department of labor
released this information yesterday
morning the new jobless claims for the
week ending march
20 came in at 684 000
the expectation was 730 000 and
um the uh revised expectation was 781
000 so
almost 100 000 fewer initial jobless
claims than expected
over the last week continuing claims are
down to 3.8 million 3.8 million
remaining unemployed versus the 4
million and 4.1 million that were
expected and revised
this is the first time new jobless
claims have been under 700 000
going back to mid-march of 2020 which is
the start of
the pandemic and really you know week to
week
the numbers can kind of go up and down
what we want to look at is trends and
new lows and we are seeing both the
continuing downward trend and a new low
now this is not oh wow everything's
fixed that's fantastic it's not that at
all and we still have so many different
issues including
jobs that are coming back as part-time
that used to be full-time
and what's funny is the when the when a
democrat is in the white house
the right always says they're not
telling you this and this and this and
this
uh but i tell you this stuff all the
time there's reasons that these numbers
are not
glorious numbers and this only has some
to do with joe biden accelerating
vaccination
certainly is a factor but there's a
seasonality to this pandemic that is
similar in much of the world
i you know i have no interest in making
things partisan
when they don't particularly need to be
there's no doubt that there are some
jobs coming back as part-time rather
than full-time
as businesses go from being open a
little bit to being fully open hopefully
in the next six months some of those
part-time jobs will become full-time
they won't all
um all sorts of other caveats we've not
dealt with the minimum wage
there are still wage issues in general
but i think if we are looking to kind of
take a cautiously optimistic approach on
the pandemic yesterday we saw that
although cases have stopped declining
hospitalizations are still declining
albeit more slowly deaths are still
declining
and vaccinations are increasing if we
think two to three months out as we get
into early summer
that's potentially a pretty good looking
situation
economically we are now starting to get
new analyses
from goldman sachs and i know many
people will say david goldman sacks
if you go back to the goldman sachs
analyses
of april 2020 in terms of vaccine
rollout
and economic numbers they were
i the most accurate i'm aware of they
correctly predicted approval for a
vaccine
in late october early november they
correctly predicted
that you would start to see healthcare
workers vaccinated
towards the end of 2020. trump was
saying it would be way sooner
some doom and gloomers were saying it
wouldn't be under until the middle of
2021
goldman sachs has been excellent on this
with their predictions i'm not telling
you go and get a goldman financial
advisor
i'm not telling you anything about
financial advisors but
the golden analysis is that the end of
2021
particularly q4 is going to look very
good by most of the economic indicators
that that we look at so the point here
is
much work to be done not the time to
start going
crazy as they've been doing in some
spring break hot spots
but the economic numbers are improving
the vaccination numbers are improving
and we're
hoping that the blip in cases is going
to continue down over the next two to
three months
i am sure that i will get some
calls from viewers in the next segment
about
what is going on with vaccination and
the pandemic
let me know your thoughts on the
expected trajectory you can find me on
twitter
at d pacman and you can also find the
show
on twitter at david pakman show
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
let's now hear from the most important
people as far as the david pakman show
is concerned it's the viewers
it's the listeners it's the trolls
and the haters and all of those people
we use discord
for our new phone system you can join at
davidpakman.com
slash discord let's start today
with cody from san diego cody you are
on the air what is going on
cody please unmute yourself we don't
want to start on such a sour note you
were on the air
cody from san diego
and the last opportunity for cody from
san diego
that's too bad that's not an auspicious
start i have to tell you
let's go next to tamisha from new york
to misha from new york please save us
hi hi how are you i'm good how are you
doing well so first of all i want to say
i liked your live stream today
talking about women as a working mother
it was really good
they know that they're actually talking
about it and thinking about it right
um but my gripe today is with black
conservatives
okay um not necessarily it
fits with all conservatives but um
candace owen has been in the scene
lately talking and she just says things
about
um people of color that just don't make
sense to me
i'm mixed so and she says things that
she sees herself like she um represents
herself and oh my experience is this
so this means that that's the experience
for everyone and i
wholly disagree with her that you can't
base your experience
on what affects other people or what
happens to other people
yeah you don't make policy around
anecdotes you make policy around
statistics
exactly like she said about um meghan
markle that
she can't possibly have experienced
racism or colorism
because she never experienced it herself
because she was she's married to a
british guy
and she never experienced herself so how
can so she thinks meghan markle's lying
candace owens is married to a british
guy you're saying
yes oh i didn't know that that's funny i
mean isn't candace
didn't candace owens grow up like in a
privileged connecticut suburb or
something like that i don't know much
about her but it seems like
i mean whatever her experience is may
may be relevant to her but as you're
pointing out it doesn't mean it's
relevant to anybody else
exactly i've seen her in videos saying
well i i
grew up poor but i overcame i worked
hard i got where i needed to be
oh okay maybe she did maybe she did i
mean i don't i don't know her story
it's just sort of like who cares what
her story is you know
exactly it's like i grew up not
privileged but i grew up okay
and i do um attribute the fact that i do
have certain privileges that other
people
i'm a lighter skinned biracial person so
i definitely know i have privileges that
maybe a darker-skinned black person
wouldn't
have right so but that doesn't mean that
i can't understand that
other people have experiences that i may
not experience yeah i mean to mesha it
would be sort of like if i said hey
listen
i i am a husband me david pakman i'm a
hispanic immigrant from argentina
i came to the us i wasn't discriminated
against
and everything's fine so clearly there's
no problem here and it's like well hold
on a second
i i'm white hispanic and i learned
english young enough where you can't
tell when you hear me
speak that i'm an immigrant it's like
what imagine if i applied my experience
and said this is how we should think
about hispanic immigration it would be
it would be ridiculous
exactly and i see that happening so much
on the right yeah where they apply their
own experience to the rest of the world
i can't talk i'm from new york i can't
talk about what happens in middle
america
they their experience is not going to be
the same as my experience
right right and it just frustrates me
yeah well you know this this is on both
sides with the right you have these
right wing
like social conservatives who are
homophobic for their whole lives
and then suddenly like their kid or
their nephew is gay or something
and they have like an awakening where
they can't imagine
what it's like they can't empathize and
then also you have what you're
describing which is they believe that
their situation is everyone's situation
um it's uh yeah it's it's the inability
to think abstractly it's only concrete
thinking that they're able to do
exactly i was told by somebody on social
media that i went to high school with
that
i'm privileged how can i talk about this
and i'm like i'm not talking about
necessarily myself i'm talking about us
as human people
right right tamesha beautiful phone call
i really appreciate it
thank you all right there's tamisha from
new york
let's go next to justin from
albany or albany new york uh i love both
pronunciations
i'm surprised uh as i i've never joined
a server before i was the first
i'm already called wow wow what's going
on
well i'm just uh curious i've been a
viewer for a while and it's just
uh with the right wing and this is a
complex issue so it's kind of hard to
like summarize it in
a couple of sentences but like i look at
like their attitude
towards lgbt people for example like
transgender youth what they were one of
their big targets and it's just like
do they do do we think that it's just do
people really just
not realize that they have an impact on
families directly who like
work hard just provide the best things
for their children do they are
targeting those type of people is it
just a convenient tool for votes or do
they really
do they really think they're doing the
right thing i don't think there's one
answer
i think the motivations are different
for different right-wingers like for
example
on on generally speaking on lgbt issues
there are some right-wingers who have
the positions they have
because either for religious reasons or
or whatever cultural reasons they are
scared of or believe that lgbt
individuals
are bad people or immoral or or
satanic or demonic or whatever there's
that group
there's also sort of more i don't know
if cynical's the right word but more
opportunistic right wingers
who see these cultural issues as wedge
issues around which you can number one
get people fired up
and number two raise money and maybe
even win elections so i don't think
there's like one
explanation to be perfectly frank
that's that's a fair point i i just i
just it's something that just
in my mind i just feel is kind of tragic
because they're just these are
real people like it's like trans youth
is like one of the big wedge issues it's
just
it just makes me sad because you know
it's just it's real people and real
families
that get impacted by that which is why
i'm passionate about that issue
well you know one good piece of news is
a study came out earlier this week a new
poll
where i guess for the first time in
history
even a majority of republicans now think
gay marriage should be legal now of
course the battle lines have moved on
that issue because gay marriage is legal
nationally and it has been for
for years it's more about you know
religious freedom to be homophobic
or trans but i i still think that the
numbers are slowly continuing to move in
the right direction
yeah that's what my friend told me which
is like i feel like most people in the
country are ready to move on from like
the gay marriage issue especially just
but yeah six years later
six years later they're starting to move
on from it that tells you how slowly
they move you know
yeah it's a fact well thanks david my
pleasure thank you for the call
uh some good calls we had that sort of
bad start with it with a dropped call
but so far it's it's going okay let's go
next to i bel is it pronounced
jate with a t from tallahassee florida
yes it is how are you can you hear me i
can hear you fine
all right um i wanted to make a very
urgent
comment okay in response to your
award-winning bonus show okay from about
two weeks ago
sure you were talking about going to a
thai restaurant
and then having some soup there right
and i have actually thai american
so i wanted to make a correction to the
product pronunciation
excuse me let me guess is it my
pronunciation of
galangal no actually
in thai that herb is known as
ka
yeah like kha is the transliteration i
think
wow but the actually i don't i don't
even know it was called
galangal in english but it was actually
the name of the soup and i think you
called it
tom yum but it's actually pronounced
wow well listen i stand corrected i
never purport to
no thai pronunciation but the soup this
is one of the i would argue globally one
of the best soups and i would not want
to disrespect it with the wrong
pronunciation so i do appreciate the
correction
yeah it's quite interesting because a
lot of americans call
pad thai with like a p-u-t
as pad thai right so that's another
common one that's out there
well listen you don't have to know how
to pronounce it to love it i think
that's the upside
for everybody listening yeah it's always
a good question as to when do you
correct pronunciation of food
in another language right kind of
interesting it's just
it's just if it's i guess if it's more
commonly had and known about then people
can
have the right pronunciation can you get
good again either
tom yum or tom yum in tallahassee
florida
actually i haven't looked for it i
haven't found it on
the menus here interesting at thai
restaurants
all right well i appreciate the call and
the correction
sure all right very good um let's go
next to a lot of corrections happening
which is fine i'm glad to be correct
corrected i want to do better let's go
to um
let's go to bobby from jersey bobby from
jersey are on the air
hi david do you hear me i do
you're kind of coming through metallic
is now better yes it is okay
uh do you think social media has
polarized
um discourse or relatively everything
especially politics
yeah i would say so yeah if so
what do you think is a better salute is
a better solution for all
to like though how do you say keep the
polarization at bay
well i i think that what you have to do
is you have to consider the dow
it's sort of like when people say if it
weren't for the internet
you wouldn't have identi some identity
theft scams
you wouldn't have cyber bullying you
know they list all the bad things
but most of us i mean pretty much
everybody i've met
still believes that the internet has
done more good than harm so it's a net
benefit
i think it's similar i mean social media
has allowed
uh it's allowed the democratization of
news reporting
it's allowed all sorts of different
people to connect and to establish
relationships it's allowed independent
media to grow and the creation of all
sorts of businesses and it's also done
lots of terrible things
i still think that that it's a net
benefit and
and i think that that's what we have to
keep in mind it's sort of like you know
go back to
agriculture agriculture is what first
allowed
the development of technology because
you had only some people working on food
production freeing others up to do
things like philosophy and building and
whatever
but it also brought diseases that come
from crowding and you know all these
different things but
i think most people would agree there's
been a net benefit from agriculture i
think you have to see
things sort of at the macro level
yes but do you think there's certain uh
regulations
uh social media companies or maybe
people on social media
should have to obey to maybe we should
like i don't know how what's your
opinion on the platforming or
i'm unclear dangerous i'm unclear that
this is something that
would be fixed by by regulation i'm not
sure about that i think we need
a big picture regulatory infrastructure
around the internet which includes net
neutrality
but as far as the individual social
network i'm just i think that the
solution really is education and media
literacy
i was about to say that yeah like media
literacy classes psychology classes and
yeah things of that nature that might uh
i say that that's my view how
people behave better yeah i don't know
that you know i don't i think you need a
regulatory framework
but i don't know that you legislate your
way out of
polarization okay i just wanted your
your opinion on that one i'm glad to
give it thank you let's take a quick
break but if you're holding don't hang
up
unless you're mad and want to hang up
but i'm going to continue taking calls
right after this very short break
the number one funding source for the
david pakman show
has been and continues to be membership
and membership
is not just a feel-good thing you get
access to the world-famous bonus show
every single day just for members as
well as commercial
free audio and video feeds of the show
day in and day out you can sign up for
membership very very quickly
at joinpacman.com that's join pakman.com
if the normal prices strike you as high
by all means use the coupon code
better21 all one word all lowercase
become a member today let's get back to
what we still call the phone lines
although they're really at this point
just internet bits
we do take calls via discord you can
find our discord
davidpakman.com slash discord
let's go next to james from new york
city you're on the air
hi um wow this is the first time i came
on the discord so
thank you pretty soon uh i was just
wondering uh
y'all i there may be like a slight lead
up to my question but
uh i wanted to talk about the new york
senatorial race uh new york city
okay uh because currently like half of
the voters are undecided at this point
so it's kind of just open
obviously we got you know yang um now
hold on a second you're saying mayoral
right because you said senatorial
oh sorry mayor mayoral okay good good
good yeah and like even recently um the
chief of the division of uh thoracic
surgery at mount sinai or raja flores
went into the race so it's just kind of
all out in the open i just i guess my
question would be uh
who is from what you've seen uh your
preferred candidate if you have one and
how do you feel about the race in
general listen i'm not really taking a
position
on it because i've not examined all of
the candidates obviously andrew yang
has been a guest on this program i think
he has great ideas
you know one of the critiques of yang
as a presidential candidate i think
serves him well
in theory as mayor which is that he's
more of like a project management guy
where he sees a lot of political issues
as
we just kind of need to take a
consultancy approach a kind of
technocrat
and new york city mayor is one of those
things where
you're going to have a bunch of people
hating you no matter what you do
and someone like yang who's just going
to sort of come in and take
this project management approach and be
guided
hopefully by data and i'm idealizing
here but
like ignore the the sort of hyperbole
around the fringes
he might be quite well suited to the job
now i know that there are people who
will say you know he's really lived
upstate
like he has this place in the city he's
not really a new york city resident okay
you know
fine like we can we can debate all that
stuff but i think some of what made him
less appealing as a presidential
candidate
makes him potentially better suited as
new york city mayor
yeah it was just a really interesting
political move when i uh i saw that you
know
yes uh well are you supporting him
um i'm not sure yet i think i'll just
kind of wait to see how things go
because again like
i think i'm kind of in the majority of
the people are kind of undecided at this
point
okay okay yeah i mean i thought he was
leading i thought he was leading the
primary
but i haven't seen him like 28 of the
vote or something
oh i see he's not he has a plurality but
not at this point well listen if there's
ten candidates you don't need a majority
oh of course yeah you know you people
drop out you know sure it's true
all right very good james we'll follow
the race for sure
james all right james is done very good
um yeah that's an interesting race
let's go next to just because we were
going to try
a foreign call let's go to
piet from germany piet from germany
you're on the air
hi dave can you hear me yes i can
my name is actually pronounced pete but
peter it's it's dutch
although i'm from germany that's allowed
no problem
okay so my credits
essentially is in germany on
the far right we have kind of the same
problem
as the u.s whereas those
normal right wingers who care about the
deficit or something like that
yeah and with those cured on people who
are
absolutely nuts who right
jesus and such stuff and my
question is how how can we fix it how
can we
get rid of those curano people because
they are as you can see with the with
the capital
until it attacked their oh my goodness
they're troubling
and they they can do a lot of harm to
you know every country they're in oh my
god
this is a crazy connection pete are you
blowing into the phone while slamming it
into a counter right now
no you're not okay listen here's the
deal
it is a long term thing to fix that
the q the fact that the the republicans
were primed to fall for like the trump
and trumpy and q and stuff doesn't
happen overnight
it's been like a 40-year programming in
the united states
so it will take a long time to do away
with it and it comes down to education
epistemology cultural change it's a big
it's probably a multi-decade
project
so i i was wondering that because
i i know you have done also videos about
how
this happened but we have the same
problem here with
you know there is no republican party
it's a party where
yeah all the kewano people are popped up
popped up like eight years ago or
something but you have q anon in germany
you're saying
yes and that is my question how can
we get rid of human i mean are they
american q anon people
who are in germany i mean they're
german but they believed the same stuff
as
the american people they they also
think bill gates is is drinking the
blood of people and
it's a great safe yeah such stuff listen
i don't know how to fix it i don't know
how to fix it here and i don't know how
to fix it there but it's disturbing that
you're also dealing with it peed
yes obviously all right pete thank you
it's an unusual connection but i was
able to um
ultimately understand the the question
and i appreciate you
um calling in for sure
let's go next to
where do we want to go how about trey
from missouri
trey you're on the air can you hear me
yes i can
so i tried calling it last week and it
just didn't work so i'm glad that i was
able to get on the air this time
i'm glad to um so obviously a big fan of
the show i had a question about purity
tests
and sort of litmus tests i was watching
one of uh the politicon panels with
you and anna casparian and kyle and
bukari and
milo and one of the things that i got
out of it was the only real litmus test
to a presidential to a candidate in any
elected office is whether they take
corporate pac money with sort of anna
casparian sort of kind of
idea do you think that that is good for
all political candidates regardless of
party and in particular on the left do
you think that that would be a winning
strategy
is if we tell democrats and democratic
leading candidates stop taking corporate
pac money
no i i listen i i don't that was a
couple of years ago and did you say
milo was on the panel i don't remember
that
no maybe not my someone someone else was
on the panel i just remember who it was
oh okay um no listen i mean the
the not taking corporate pac money is a
great thing
and i'm i love seeing more candidates
doing that
i don't think that that is like the
deciding line as to whether someone
is or isn't a good candidate and there's
there's districts where that probably
wouldn't even make a difference so no i
i mean listen in politics there's very
few like hard and fast rules
and i i want to get corporate pac money
out
uh we should we need campaign finance
reform but no it's not like the be-all
end-all but it's a great thing i i think
in some places it won't make a big
difference
all right i just had a question about
that i just i know that there are some
people on the progressive left who want
that to be d and all be all standard
well i don't i don't know who want who
says that that's the be all end-all
standard uh tray but it's certainly
something to aspire to i just don't
think at this point it's it's yet like a
difference maker or needs to be
necessarily a litmus test in all
districts
all right thank you david no problem uh
there is trey from missouri with things
not muted in the background but we're
tolerating all of it of course
let's go next to tyler and vancouver our
friendly neighbors to the north
okay hear me yes i can tyler can you
hear me
yes i can tyler i'm doing well excellent
i have a question
i'm sure if you've covered this before
but it seems from afar that the
republican party and its supporters have
laid
claim to this idea of american
patriotism in the name of their cause
and no one else's
um i don't know if it's become a big
recruiting tool for american right but
it feels like it's
everyone who's not with them is an
anti-american fascist right yeah no this
is this is not new i mean
in i it probably goes back many decades
but as far as i've been covering
politics during the george w
bush era if you didn't support the war
in iraq you weren't really a patriot
that became a big
a big um talking point then
yeah and so my question is how how has
it become that
the right has laid claim to patriotism
and how can what can the left do to you
know reclaim that
from them uh yet george lakoff has has
written about this quite a bit
the the right has not only succeeded on
taking
patriotism they've succeeded on on
framing and branding on a bunch of
different issues
you know pro-life sounds great
and they succeeded on that tax relief
is another one that george lake wow
that's a relief you're removing the
burden of taxation
this is not unique to patriotism and i i
don't have any
um uh unique ideas on it other than to
say
i would look at lake off on this and
some of his suggestions and
democrats just aren't very good at this
i mean listen if it were me
i would say patriotism should be about
look at how well we take care of
everybody from the standpoint of health
care
look at how well designed our cities are
to have great public transit and green
spaces
and connection between richer and poorer
you know none of these things are true
now but
like those would be the types of things
for me that seem like the ones i would
want to be
patriotic about rather than like we have
the most weapons or
we you know have the most guns or or
whatever i i think it needs to be a
complete paradigm shift on framing
i completely agree and just on one more
note on that
is that how how i should
try to figure out the best way to to
kind of ask this is
if if the left's ideas are somehow seen
as anti-american you know like repealing
or
not repealing the second amendment but
you know having stronger gun
uh security kind of stuff how can
we fight against that being an
anti-american value when it's
just not you know it's a better for the
entire country
it's really just a pr it's unfortunately
merely a propaganda and rhetorical war
at this point so you just have to be
better at rhetoric
that that's that simple yeah this is
kind of a shame that's what paul says
come to this day
i know there you go i agree with you i
agree with you i appreciate the call
thanks so much
tyler from vancouver thank you so much
for the call
very much appreciate it let's go
next to a chase from new hampshire
you're on the air
um hi so i actually did have a question
about um
i forgot sorry okay that
sorry oh actually uh you should pick uh
live free from watch next i'm sorry but
if he has a question
okay a chase from new hampshire
blacklisted
but i mean i'll try it we usually i
usually don't go to anyone who doesn't
have like a real name
listed but um let's try it let's go to
live free from washington who somehow is
already
unmuted what's going on with that oh i'm
one of your mods david what's up
you can unmute yourself that sounds like
too much power
it's too much power yeah what's going on
um
oh i wanted to ask you a question sorry
i'm live
chase uh i wanted to ask you the same
question that i asked the consul general
and uh
and uh from the canadian embassy in
seattle well i can't imagine that we
have the same background and expertise
but i will try
i wanted to ask what you thought of the
north american union if you're familiar
with the concept
the north american union is this between
canada the u.s and maybe mexico
sir well you just cut out hold on what
was that did you say yes
i did oh what would be the it would be a
union
an economic union what what exactly are
the details
it would be an economic union in
addition to a political union uh think
of like the european union but a more
federated state
i mean without knowing you know i would
the way i would think about it would be
i would want to hear
what are the parameters of the union and
what did do solid economic analyses
say would be the impact just in a vacuum
it's hard to say
it's a good idea or it's a bad idea i
don't know
i i wouldn't wait would the idea be to
uh what would the point of it be would
it be to
um negotiate in a particular way to
align wages i mean
you know i'm just unsure what the what
the point would be
uh well my idea at least would be the
utilization of transfer payments to
levelize like the total economic
capacity of these different regions uh
bring up the standard of living in
different regions have a larger
organizational capacity to like organize
against other blocks of countries or
regions
yeah especially as we move forward uh
that'd be my general kind of
idea i would evaluate it in the context
of geopolitics
knowing with china and russia as the two
other big super powers
with you know india nigeria as a growing
power
uh the i i would think about it more in
terms of what it would do
geopolitically from the standpoint of
american interests now if you want to
say would it be better for canada or
mexico those are different
calculations but i would want to see an
economic analysis that would look at it
from what does it mean for the united
states in a geopolitical context
geopolitics is definitely the first lens
which i look at this through i mean the
same thing with ttp and ttip
um you know looking at i mean containing
is probably the wrong word but
utilizing trade mechanisms to limit the
expansion of china's influence you know
and other factors it's completely
conceivable
that economists would look at it and say
that's a good idea
i think it's basically an academic
question because you and i probably
both would agree that's this isn't going
to happen well it's an academic
question definitely in the next 50 years
or so but i
you know thinking broader and beyond
that i i yeah
i would ironically call myself a
globalist and think it's a good idea
and you're not saying you're not using
that as code for jewish as money right
no
no no no oh no no no i'm just mean like
globalization of rights sorry people are
laughing at me
you're not saying i'm jewish you're
saying you are actually a globalist
yes no i'm saying i'm actually a global
goddess
all right very good i appreciate the
call all right you have a good day david
all right well rescuing the abortive
call from chase from new hampshire
that is going to do it for today i'm
sorry i wasn't able to get to
everybody but we will take calls again
if i have anything to say about it
we'll take a quick break and be right
back after this
the david pakman show is audience
supported media and you can contribute
any amount you want on patreon as little
as one dollar per month
plus you can get the daily bonus show
world famous at this point
and the daily commercial free tv show
by making those pledges at patreon.com
slash david pakman show this is audience
supported media we depend on the support
of our viewers and listeners
whether you listen to the podcast watch
on youtube or watch us on tv
or even listen on the radio patreon.com
davidpakmanshow let's get right into
audience questions today
last set of audience questions before
our little vacation
and then we'll be back and we'll take
more of them cancel culture
got a very interesting question we know
that david
that the right hates cancel culture
supposedly
but how do they believe it should be
fixed anyway
isn't any quote solution authoritarian
by
by definition this is a great point
essentially all answers for how the
right wants to
fix the problem of cancel culture are
extremely authoritarian other than just
like
culture changing where people don't say
when they don't like something anymore
which i don't know how you achieve um
i don't know how you would ban cancel
culture or the fact that actions have
consequences and
sometimes people will tweet about it
sometimes people will tell a business
i'm not going to buy your product
because of this or that or the other
thing that
you as a company said or one of your
employees said or whatever
any of those actions would be
authoritarian and they would be
against what they claim their views to
be
remember the right says they're about
free speech and people getting to say
what they want and business is not being
regulated
any way that you try to fix what they
define as cancel culture would either
require
limiting businesses regulating
businesses somehow so they can't act
on whatever information they want
assuming it's not illegal like someone's
race or religion
to say we don't want to work with you
anymore you're fired or whatever
that's very heavy-handed authoritarian
business regulation which the right
claims to be against
saying people don't have the right to
tweet their displeasure at what a
celebrity or a business said
they don't have the right to announce
and carry out
a boycott on a business because that's
what they want to do it's all
insanely authoritarian there
would be no conceivable legislative
solution
to quote cancel culture that wouldn't
violate or in some other ways limit
violate the first amendment or limit
speech
so what you have to once you understand
there's no legislative way to deal with
cancer culture
you have to realize that the continued
demands from the right
to deal with cancer culture either
go against the very first amendment they
claim to defend
or are merely pandering and that's one
of the most important things i think
that we can take away from this
discussion which is that many of these
right-wingers and some on the left
who are talking about cancel culture not
as something that happens infrequently
and that we should really and think
about and evaluate
and say what what makes sense
when they are talking about it they
don't even really want a solution
in the sense that they know there isn't
going to be one this is just a cultural
reality elections
uh uh rather i'm sorry speech elections
do have consequences
speech has consequences and those
consequences in most cases are also
protected by the first amendment as far
as the government is involved by
business freedom when businesses are
involved etc
now we can't ignore the huge hypocrisy
from the right on this issue
who are the two biggest victims of
cancellation that you can think of
over the last 20 years for me they're
clear it's the dixie chicks
who were are a country music
uh band but when they came out against
george w bush's foreign policy
the right which is very intertwined with
country music
canceled them they were blacklisted from
so many radio stations
and the right said dixie chicks are over
colin kaepernick these two biggest
instances
of these cancellations that the right
claims to be against were done by the
right
and then you had people throwing you
know keurigs out the window
starbucks was bad the nfl for the
kneeling
amazon for saying we're not gonna host
parlor um
you know taylor swift when she came out
and took political positions
the right loves to cancel people using
their terminology but they claim to be
against it and so this entire thing is a
ruse now as i talked about
last week um uh during during our
interview
um with with professor kavalak
just because we can identify some
instances where someone was wrongly
shamed or fired doesn't mean we call
this an epidemic and he actually agreed
with me
on that issue and um you bring me
a wrong decision that was made and if it
was indeed made wrongly i'll be right
there with you it's no no problem
whatsoever
but we can't allow these right-wingers
to claim they're against cancel culture
when they're some of the biggest
cancelers look at what republicans did
to cindy mccain
cindy mccain the widow of the late
senator john mccain
was censured because she didn't want to
vote for trump she wasn't voting for
trump
they are complete and total hypocrites
and this is really getting to the key
thing which is any solution that they
would propose would be extraordinarily
authoritarian and arguably against the
first amendment
and many of don't don't really want
solutions they just want to pander and
unfortunately
it's working very well they're getting a
lot of mileage out of this dr
seuss cancel culture stuff david do you
think
vaccination phases are ethical once you
get to vaccinating
healthcare workers is it really ethical
to limit who can get the vaccine beyond
that
i mean listen this is basic utilitarian
uh utilitarianism it's triage
you try to reduce the amount of death
and people who get seriously ill from
covid if that's the goal
if we all agree that those statistically
more likely to get
a cold flu-like
are in one group and those statistically
more likely to die from covid are in
another group
it's completely utilitarian to say they
get the vaccine first so you would start
with
the oldest folks and those with the most
serious medical conditions there's
nothing
particularly unique about that it's
simply utilitarianism
now where it can get tricky is
the practice of figuring out where some
of these lines are so
for example throughout the pandemic
grocery store workers have been
essential essential workers we've heard
the term
but they've not been prioritized
we know that so many um grocery store
workers have gotten sick with the virus
and we're saying they're essential but
they're not being prioritized
maybe it's being done incorrectly but
the idea of figuring out
at least when there's limited supply who
can get the vaccine
first is perfectly utilitarian now
you can look at other criteria you could
say
well we want this to be egalitarian and
so we're going to do it by
lottery as an example you could make the
case that
that's preferable in some way it's not
likely to reduce death
the studies that i've looked at do say
that starting with the oldest and the
sickest
is is the way to reduce that death and
in fact we're seeing it if you look at
the numbers now
cases have sort of plateaued they've
plateaued right around 50
000 a day and hospitalizations keep
declining
and deaths keep declining now the deaths
are on a delay from cases so we'll have
to continue to watch that but that makes
sense
because you you tend to have people
behave in a way that's reflective of the
risk they perceive
there are definitely younger people as
we now learn
about more and more older folks being
vaccinated there are more younger people
doing whatever the hell they want
spreading covet is leading to cases
but the deaths and hospitalizations are
going down
because the most vulnerable have already
been vaccinated so i
i do believe that as vaccine supply
increases the restrictions
probably become i don't know if the word
is less ethical but less necessary
and certainly any thawed vaccine should
be used no matter what there are some
anecdotal stories and we've covered some
of them of people who have been
penalized and in some cases i believe
even fired
for using open doses which would go bad
if you leave them overnight
on people who did not yet meet criteria
i i think that's terrible
and to the extent that it's happening
anecdotally it shouldn't it's very bad
people we should be using every single
dose a dose
in a trash can is never better no matter
what
than a dose in someone's arm but yes
from a utilitarian standpoint and this
is
a common way to analyze some of these
medical ethics issues
there's nothing unethical about the
vaccine triage
and it does appear as though it's being
done more or less in the right way but
there are arguments to be made about
well
teachers maybe should have been earlier
if they're going to have to be in
schools with kids
um if grocery workers really are
essential we know
a lot of them are getting sick they
should be on i think you can tweak
with with some of the specifics but
there's nothing unethical in principle
david you've talked before about how the
modern republican party under trump is
basically just about owning the libs and
memes it's no longer about policy
does it matter if they keep on winning i
mean listen they didn't win
they lost in 2018 and they lost in 2020
so it's not clear that they're
continuing to win
but i think the the important question
is
when you have so many republicans who
don't really know anything about policy
and you have so many republicans that no
matter what aren't voting for democrats
policy really doesn't matter very much
when you put out policy and then you
fail
and then your constituents don't hold
you accountable anyway
why bother putting out policy at all and
there are some republicans who are
actually taking this uh
and running with it madison cothorn this
new trumpian
elected republican member of the house
of representatives um
one of his aides i think it was someone
in his circle said
we're not running a policy office we're
running a communications office which is
social media and interviews and
confrontations that that are visually
compelling and this type of thing
these are their voters right and if they
don't need to put out policy and risk
failing to achieve it and the voters are
more interested in ways to own the libs
and
memes and this type of thing then
they're going to be that's what they're
going to get and in fact
it's happening republican voters have
been fed a constant stream of propaganda
for about six years now right it's 2021
you go back to 2015 when trump started
uh running and they've rewarded this
behavior
the guy who said without any details i'm
going to get rid of obamacare and do
something beautiful
i'm going to build a wall across the
entire border i'm going to fix trade
except he ended up you know replacing uh
nafta with the i don't even remember
what it's called now but it was
more or less the exact same thing
they're fed the propaganda and they
reward the candidates that feed it to
them
they're represented by the political
equivalent of internet trolls and they
love it and when your priority is
messing with the other side
making liberals feel bad or look bad or
whatever
it becomes a feedback loop the
propaganda of fox news and of
republicans
gives an alternate reality to the
republican voter
so that the republican voter no longer
cares about policy
and they use the propaganda to say well
i can't vote for biden because he's a
communist
socialist i can't vote for hillary
because she has parkinson's or whatever
the case
may be and then they don't and then it
makes it so republicans continue to say
why run on policy i'll run on memes
and this goes for elected officials this
goes for fox news newsmax oan
that's how they they push this stuff and
generally speaking
it works now you can make the case well
does it work they lost the house in 2018
they lost the senate in 2020 they lost
the white house in 2020.
i just have a hard time believing that
policy would have done
better for them because their voters
have been so propagandized too and
that's the question i'll leave to you
is there an advantage i know that some
of the
traditional republicans you get back
with a focus on policy
assuming it's the right policy but do
they lose
all of these trumpies who never paid
attention to politics to begin with
and just showed up for the mexican
rapists type comments
is it really a net benefit to go back to
policy for the republican party
let me know what you think bonus show
today
this is the last show and bonus show
before our break we are off next week
the show's not canceled everything's
fine we're just taking a week off to
regenerate some energy
and then we'll be back the week after
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25
percent off a subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman